give me a nick you may get married today
and now you okay
there's always been fireworks between
Drake and Nicki Minaj I actually believe
that Drake kind of fell hard for Nicki
Minaj like he publicly tweeted about how
he wanted to marry her and I believe
that Nicki might have actually enjoyed
this because it actually boosted her
reputation and her fame just a little
bit both stars know how to play it up to
the press this BBC Radio 1 interview is
no exception what will the children be
like they'll have drinks intelligence
they'll have his you know sarcastic you
know wittiness that I love about him I
think that that made Drake fall even
harder for Nicki and Nicki just kind of
enjoyed the success of having this
little media fling I always have respect
and I love for Nicki and unfortunately
Gavin we haven't spoke last year on
beats one Drake opened up to Zane Lowe
about their falling-out that was likely
fueled by the beef he had with her
then-boyfriend Meek Mill but even though
meek and Nicki have officially called it
off the nature of her relationship with
Drake
kind of remains a mystery things were a
bit more obvious when Drake spent a
steamy summer with Serena Williams after
all they were caught getting
affectionate on camera hanging on for
the massive upset victory but Serena
would end the sunny season with a
shocking loss at the US Open and all the
blame shifted to her man in the stands
sometimes if a relationship is too
possessive or a little bit too centered
around one person it can be a huge
distraction and I think that Drake based
on his history has been a little bit
spoiled in his relationships he's a
little bit self-centered and so if he
was acting a little bit controlling or
non encouraging of Serena's personal
activities this really could have
affected her performance in the US Open
and though serena later said it wasn't
fair for people to place the blame on
Drake we never heard anything more from
the rumored couple ever again
somewhere in between Nikki and Serena
Drake found a new musical muse in
Rihanna
when the romance rumors followed
everyone kind of wondered are they on
are they off like what is going on
between them from reported romantic
dinners at the CN tower to steamy scenes
in music videos many thought Rihanna
could really be the one next came an
epic declaration of love from Drake at
the MTV Video Music Awards that seemed
like a fairytale ending I think this
kind of took the control away from her
she had no say in how this was portrayed
to the public and we all know that
Rihanna is very careful about the image
that she puts out to her fans Drake has
a history of kind of having these online
and media flirtations with women but
then he turns around and says no I'm
serious and I think that can really
scare some people away Drake has since
been romantically linked to Jennifer
Lopez although the only thing that we
really know for a fact is that they've
collaborated musically JLo is just one
of several women who have never really
confirmed whether or not their did many
people think that Drake is a player but
I actually think he's kind of a closeted
relationship a holic he falls hard he
puts it all on the table too soon
instead of kind of going through the
typical wooing process that every man
has to go through he thinks that he's
just able to get them because he's so
rich and he's so famous and he's such a
star but when it comes to relationships
Drake is just like everyone else and he
needs to work hard